Airport system. We will now transition to
Houston Health and Director
Williams director
Stephen Williams and Darren Asher and council member,
pilot, vice chair. Would you step in the seat, council Member Jackson,
1 minute.
At this time, I want to welcome director Stephen Williams and Darren
Asher to provide the Houston Health Department budget. The floor is
yours.
Good afternoon. As you said,
I'm Stephen Williams, director of the Houston Health Department. I'm here
to present our General Fund and Special Fund budget
for the fiscal year 2023. I want
to start by introducing my staff there behind me, so I don't know where they
are. I have with me Judy Harris,
who's Chief of Staff and deputy director.
Also Darren Asher, who's our chief financial
officer and administration. Also is Amber Hague,
who's behind me, also who does one part of our administration.
Stepping in for our communications officer is Dr. Faith Foreman,
who's administratively over that unit right now. But you should
be familiar with portfolio Villarrell, who is our
Pio and Councilor Liaison.
Also with me is my assistant, Randy Presley assistant Director,
Patrick Key, over Environmental Naomi Macys,
assistant Director for Clinical and Multi Service Center Operations,
Dr. Shannon Bivens, the Deputy Director for Public Health, Evelyn Schaefer,
deputy Director of Human Services and
Financial Division Manager, Shamika Marshall
I want to express publicly my gratitude for
the staff, especially during the last two and a half years.
Although for you all, things might seem relatively calm in the
community. With rates of COVID slowly rising,
we're still providing testing and vaccination services to
the community. At the same time, we're resetting these
services that we have within the Houston Health Department
and transitioning to what we would call
possibly a new normal. But I don't know that any of us really knows
what that is. Now go to the next slide,
please, with vision, mission and goals. Our mission
is to work in partnership with the community to promote and protect the health and
social well being of Houstonians and the environment in which they live.
It's not practical to try to do public health alone.
Community involvement is key to our success. Our partnerships were
certainly instrumental in our ongoing COVID response, certainly related
to testing and vaccinations and the
critical for effective interventions within the community.
We don't think that we can do it all.
We exist in public health to improve access to
care, to prevent spread of infectious disease to
promote opportunities for healthy living and reduce burden of chronic
disease which most people die from protect the community
from environmental hazards to improve health and well being through
human services improve health of mothers, infants and children
and prepare to respond to disasters and emergencies.
And certainly we try to do that in a culture of excellence.
Next slide, please. This is
our functional organizational chart. In our General Fund,
it supports 374 positions. Within our Special
Funds, it supports 285 positions which totals
about 660 FPS between those two funds.
Our administration, I'll tell you, is just 9.9%
of the General Fund, especially funds.
But I have to add in our grant funds. Our grant funds support
675 positions and this is
not including COVID sources.
Those funds are approximately $63 million.
That will be a total for normal operations of about 1336
FTEs for Florida department administration is 7.6%
of that. Well, we have COVID with the $91 million
that we have annually for COVID. You need to add another 485
positions to that, bringing our total positions within the health
department now to 1821 for the entire department.
Administration of all of that is still reduced to
6.3% of our budget. And I say that because
without administration we can't really get the job done.
I'm extremely proud of the scope of the programs and
services that we provide. Although in some of our
programs I do not believe that the scale in programs like
our Don, our Reentry program, see to Succeed, our scale should certainly
be much broader to match the scale of the problem of
the condition that exists here in the city of Houston.
The next slide is a summary of our major services.
Did something different this year? I wanted to
give you an idea of how much the General Fund supports public health
within this community.
If you look at the services that are highlighted in green, you will see that
our General Fund primarily supports environmental health,
which has food safety, special waste and pools.
Our clinical services out of four health centers,
eleven multi service centers, and hopefully in the
2023 budget year we'll add on a leaf and
with a new Sunnyside facility, thank God, and a regional
lab. But if you look at those programs that are in red,
there's limited or no General Fund support for those programs.
TB, Immunizations, Maternal and Child Health
C to Succeed, which provides free vision exams and
glasses to children. My brother's keeper reentry.
Certainly WIC is a grant funded program. All of our COVID operations and
testing and vaccine is supported by grants. The programs
that I did mention are primarily supported through grants and special revenue
funds. Next slide, please.
This slide lists state and local codes and ordinance that mandates
some of the public health services that we provide, such as Disease
Prevention and Control, environmental Regulatory service and vital statistics.
Chapter One and 121. The Public Health Reorganization Act authorizes
municipalities to enforce laws to protect public health,
receive grants, appoint a local health authority. And that would be Dr.
David Purse. Our local ordinances, chapter 21 and
22 establishes the local health department.
Subsequent ordinances establish certain programs such as air pollution and
vital statistics. Next slide, please.
The medical nature of our operations requires specialized
licenses and certification. This has a major impact
on recruitment intention given our proximity to the medical center.
As I mentioned in the past, our department was the first health
department in Texas to become accredited. We was the second major
city in the country to become Fab accredited during
the Pandemic. We became reaccredited, and we are accredited for
the next five years to 2026.
With the accreditation, hopefully we can demonstrate increased accountability
and credibility to the public, to the funders, certainly to you and
partner organizations which we work with.
Next slide, please.
Licenses and certification that are required. Our business requires certain licenses
and certification, as you can see the
requirements for a laboratory and pharmacy. I want to
highlight that our lab does not only support our clinics, but it's a specialty lab
supporting 17 surrounding counties. Our stat lab
provides onsite lab testing and our specific multi service
clinics. The Bureau of Laboratory Services provide a variety
of clinical and environmental testing and support of various
health department programs, including our lead TB,
Epidemiology, Environmental Services, Hi V.
STD. Our wastewater surveillance.
And I want to really highlight wastewater surveillance because it
has really gotten national attention. It's a partnership
with Rice thanks to Carol Hednock and Public
Works and her folks are very cooperative during the Pandemic having
their staff actually collecting those samples.
We have actually been a source of support for other
jurisdictions within the country that are wanting to
get into wastewater testing because they see ours as a model,
given that the Public Works
wastewater system as it exists within the
city. Of course, with wastewater surveillance,
we're able to predict COVID-19 trends from one to two weeks
before other surveillance metrics like testing.
And of course, we use that information to guide our
strategies related to COVID. I have to tell
you that even though the numbers are low now,
we're still concerned with several geographical areas
within the city where there are low vaccination rates coupled
with other social economic challenges.
Hopefully you will be seeing a number of contracts
where we're trying to partner with more community based organizations
to have further reach into those specific communities.
The next slide, please. I have been doing this presentation for
about 18 years, and I have to always do this slide just
to highlight the level of investment, the general fund investment,
and the health department. Overall.
This slide illustrates the city's net fund general
fund investment in public health. It's only for $40 million.
The Health Department's 23 target is $65
million. 2 million of that is to cover environmental health special
revenue funds. But please understand that we generate
$25.6 million in revenue. That's where
we get that number from. But it's also to
note that out of $40 million investment,
19 million is in restricted funds, which means
that I only have control of $20 million in general
fund to really do public health
programming and that's of a
budget of $165,000,000
totally if you include our grants and other special
funds. The next slide,
please. Our revenues by Fund Fund
100 represents an increase of $3 million
in revenue, and it's related to multiple grants in support of
COVID-19 that are generating additional indirect cost
recovery. When we bring in grants, we hire people,
we actually increase the bottom line of the General Fund because of
indirect cost. This revenue is
driven directly by our ability to hire grant
staff, which means the more grant staff we hire, the more indirect
dollars we can actually draw down from the grants.
In Fund 22, an increase
of approximately $2 million reflects a one time transfer
from the General Fund to cover our environmental health experience
expenses. This program staff activity
actually generate enough revenue to cover the program expenses.
Fund 2010 represents a reduction of approximately
$3.1 million in revenue due to the 1115
waiver actually coming to an end, we are slated to
get our last payment in July of this year.
Overall, in our budget you will see an increase in revenue of $2.2
billion.
The next slide actually is a highlight of
the summary of revenue by Fund. I'm not going to go over that because if
you go to the next slide, I can actually talk more specifically about
those funds and Fund 100, the expenditure
breakdown. Of course, 60% of the General Fund supports
personnel for administrative services, environmental health,
oral health and clinical staff, and the health Clinics laboratory
Morality Service Centers. It's really a repeat of what I said before.
40% of the General Fund supports non personnel items.
Of that, I'd just like to note that only 18% of the non personnel
funds support departmental operations. We primarily rely on
grant and special revenue funds to make ends
meet when it comes to buying equipment,
supplies and services.
The next slide, please. Expenditures by Funds
this slide is a summary, so I'm going to go to the next page,
which breaks it down by detail.
All funds highlight expenditure highlights. In Fund 1000,
expenditures increased by $5.5 million
due to $1.2 million in hope
and pension increases. $1.6 million for new
a leaf facility, which only represents the
third time in 18 years that I've actually gotten General Fund money
for programs in public health. The only other two times
was when we needed more overtime
in jail health, which was a mandated services,
and we got a cut in federal dollars for our TB services
and we needed to backfill some of those dollars. So I'm grateful.
Even though it's the third time in 18 years.
Fund 2002 increases include additional
funds for expansion of our AAA Veterans Affairs program.
Of course, that's grant funded funds in 2008 2009
there were no significant changes, and funds in 2010
no significant changes. But as I said, we're getting that
last payment for that in July of this year.
Fund 2023 Special Waste Fund reflects
the transfer eleven FTEs to the Health Special Revenue Fund from
2002 as part of the department's attempt to
reduce expenditures. Really, this is
really charging a portion of consumer health staff
to this Fund. The next slide,
please.
Personnel versus non personnel in Fund 22.
This is a catch. All fund used to manage revenue that is generated
for a variety of programs. This includes Environmental
Consumer Health RFID program,
which is really the RFIDs that you have on the
food trucks. Our Veterans Affairs that I mentioned
earlier, medicaid Administrative Claiming, which is really
based on a cost report that we are due for providing services
related to Medicaid clients and also
vital records and parking garage fees.
54% of all funds support personnel.
This is related to the issuance of ambulance permitting
support the Veterans Administration program by assisting
veterans with services staffing to support parking garage
at our stadium facility and staff to support
nondirect services paid for with Medicaid dollars
such as billing.
46% of those are of those funds
are non personnel items. 3% is in restricted accounts.
The 72% is for non subrecipient contracts
and basically that's used in environmental health to replace obsolete
equipment in our RFID program and to
operate our Digital Health Online food Managers class.
Next slide, please. In laboratory services. This is pretty straightforward.
The revenue from this Fund supports our lab operations and provides
funding for laboratory equipment and laboratory and
and laboratory services.
A lot of our grants I'd like to mention actually support some of our laboratory
services too, but this is the General Fund
supportive Personnel and non personnel on swimming pools.
69% of the Fund supports personnel.
31% supports supplies and services,
including mandatory education and training and testing supplies.
The Fund 2010 Essential Public Health Services
want to take a little bit more time to highlight what this Fund had actually
done over the last few years? This 1115
waiver supports both waiver
programs and essential public health core
services. In the past years, we have used these funds to
support general operations, general Fund operations such as
laboratory services, TB control, maintenance contracts
and clinic supplies. This Fund has been a lifesaver
for the Department operation and allowed us to be responsive in the
emergencies. Over the last ten years, we have minimized the
negative impact of General Fund reductions over the last
few years by using these funds.
We have an average of about 200 FTEs supported
through this Fund. Over the past five years, we have
funded programs, as I said earlier, like C to Succeed. Projecting savior smiles,
my brother's keeper reentry supported lab services,
our Don program, chronic disease, as well as our
administrative services division. These funds
are limited. So in the next year, what you will see is
a restructuring plan to reduce both FTEs and operational
support.
Next slide please. Fund 24 23
special waste our fog program. Basically,
this Fund supports our fat, soil and grease inspections.
It includes support for 48.3 FTEs.
The Fund is 84% personnel and supports those
activities. 16% of the Fund support operations,
36% is allocated to restricted accounts
and 64% is allocated to supply services and equipment.
Next slide, please. 2023 budget
Expenditure net Changes okay,
of course, the first section covers the $61.1
million, which is our current FY 21 22
budget. Excuse me. Section two
covers the operational operating budget adjustments.
You see in that adjustments for
our 1115 waiver, our intergovernmental
transfer funds, and also where we had received some council
funds. The third section contractual
mandated adjustments related to benefits, restricted accounts
and our new a leaf facility. As I mentioned earlier.
The fourth section is the proposed budget includes $2.2
million transfer to the Special Health Revenue Fund for community
health and environmental consumer health. Those are to fund those
to transfer those eleven positions to that cost center.
The current budget minus operating adjustments, plus mandated adjustments
equal to a budget of $65.6 million,
which is a 7.4% increase in our
General Fund budget. The next slide
gives our budget history. Probably need to explain it
to you a little bit, because if you note in
FY 19, the adopted budget does what didn't
include jail health. But remember, we had to operate jail health for
an additional year because the Joint Processing
Center didn't open for another year.
In FY 22, the estimate includes a 1.2 restricted account
adjustment for the $750,000
hope adjustments in FY 21.
Just so that you will understand what
we did there in that fiscal year, we redeployed
General Fund staff to work COVID and so we built those expenses
to those COVID grants which resulted in
a reduced expenditures to the General Fund.
And in FY 22 you will also see
that resulted in the restricted accounts increase,
which basically it is going to charge us more than what we
have budgeted because we brought on more people and more computers.
That pretty much explains that.
That's the end of my financial budget presentation
for FY 23.
Thank you Director, for your presentation. A couple of questions.
What are the areas of our city that have the low vaccination
rates? I'm not going to guess. Why don't I send you
the map that we have? During the height of COVID
we actually did a weekly report showing
areas that were concerned, there were target areas,
just what we characterized as high COVID vulnerability
areas based on an index that was produced by developed by
CDC. Yeah, if you could send that to all of our offices, that would be
great. We have some areas,
I'm sure. Let's go to slide
eight, please.
So to get clarification on this slide
again, with 40
million, you all are able to generate revenues of 25 million.
Yes. So if we were to allocate more dollars
to you from the General Fund, would you be able to also generate more revenue?
Probably not, because the areas that generate the revenue
are primarily in our environmental health area where we're collecting fees
for permits. If I had more General Fund
dollars, of course I would spend them in programmatic areas. I think
we need to focus more on chronic disease. I think we need to focus
more on balance,
youth balance. And I think that we
need to also focus more on maternal child health issues.
So comparison for the general fund dollars that we allocate
estimated, how many dollars will you get in grants?
I can tell you what we know that we're going to get. We're going to
get about $65 million in the coming
year in grants, and that's all over the map.
We will have probably about $91 million
in COVID dollars, but those dollars are going to end in about a year.
So the $65 million you'll get
in grants, is that including the COVID dollars or no?
No. So outside of the COVID dollars, you're still going to get around estimated
$65 million in grants? Yes. And that's about what
we usually get. Our budget for the last couple of years have been running about,
what, $160,000,000,000 within that range
for everything special funds, general funds, and grants. You want
to use your microphone, Mr. Ashley, for everything, special funds,
general funds, and grants by 165. Thank you.
Next, we have questions by Council member Amy Peck.
Thank you, Vice Chair. And thank you, Director, for the presentation.
When you were talking about the 1115 waiver restructuring
and adjusting and moving personnel from that fund, can you just
talk about that a little bit more for clarity? So you're moving
personnel from the 1115 waiver that we were using to pay for their
salaries to where's that money coming from now?
Well,
and I'm sure you've heard this from other department directors, but the
general fund doesn't support some of the essential
programs that I think our department should be running back.
Starting in, I think, 2011, 2012, we were
able to access 1115 Waiver funds.
With those funds, we were able to bring on programs
that I thought we needed to be running
within the Health Department. For example, see, to succeed
my Brother's Keeper program, our reentry program
is funded by 1115 Waiver.
So when those the 200 positions I
mentioned, I can't just put them on the general fund. The general
fund can't absorb them. So I will have to find other
resources if we want to keep those services. If I'm not
able to recoup enough
revenue, we will have to actually reduce those services.
Okay, so at this point, you're just looking for grants and other ways to pay
for them. You're not moving anybody to the general fund that
was on the 1115 waiver? My boss wouldn't let me do
that. Okay. And then my
last question is about environmental health. Something I've
talked to Public Works about when it comes to inspections is
working with other departments so that we're looking at if it's
an apartment complex or a house that needs certain inspections, that we're working
together and not working separately. So can
you just talk a little bit about how well that has been from your
perspective, working with Public Works to make sure that everything is being inspected
kind of all at once? I think we have a very good working relationship
with Public works, especially as it relates to the apartment complex,
because sometimes a complaint will come into one
department or the other. And our staff has
been around long enough that they know what's our scope of responsibility
and know to bring those other departments in.
I think that the Waste Water Surveillance Initiative is a
good example of how Public Works and our department are
working well together. One thing that it's in the
works. I haven't really told staff about this, but they'll know now. Council Member
Kayman is carol and I
were out at an event related to lead and we thought
that we could actually broaden those activities because of
just the age of the houses. And in the last week or so,
we're passing emails back and forth talking about how we
were going to approach this.
Council Member Sally Alcorn. Thank you,
Vice Chair. And thank you, Director, for all the great work you've done during COVID
on slide four. Thank you for that. The red and green one.
You were talking about administrative funds, and I wanted to be clear.
Those grant funds do come with administrative funds built in.
You're not supporting all of those with general fund admin?
No. Yeah, we couldn't support and they have
varying percentages, I'm sure, of administrative funds associated with
those. They do. Okay, great.
Houston permitting and I rarely get any complaints about
the Health Department. Houston part of Houston Permitting.
How many employees do you I mean, I know swimming pool safety and then what
else do you do? Like at HPC? Do you know how many FTEs are over
there in the permitting system from hell? No, I don't. But Patrick,
four total. Okay.
And on temporary employees, you mentioned that as we are seeing decreases
in COVID and the grants funding,
I mean, do you anticipate that some of the temporary employees or some of
the people we've taken on will not no longer be I mean,
how long do you anticipate most of the COVID related temporary employees?
Well, an interesting thing has happened during COVID especially during this point
in our other programs, whether they're grant funded
in some general fund positions. We have a lot of vacancies on that side.
So those individuals that have been working no good. Yeah.
We are looking to figure out whether or
not there is a fit. We don't want to run the
risk of letting everybody go and then we go into another
surgeon. So we're engaging in some cross training.
Sure. Okay. And finally, I was going to ask the
kinder and Hobby School study that talked about a
tale of two departments that came out in December. Did recommend
some areas where we could possibly do an MoU with
the county. Not talking about merging departments or anything.
Don't beat me up between us.
Okay. But if you could opine a bit.
They list several areas of overlap and disease control
and prevention, dental services, environmental, public health,
women and Children's health, Nutrition and Chronic Disease Program, public Health
Awareness Policy and Planning and Finance Administration.
I mean, could we start small with some MoUs? And you've
done a good job, like with air quality monitoring and stuff like that with the
county, but where could we do an additional MoU to possibly
gain Efficiencies one day? Okay, I'm going to make a general comment
because they made a comment publicly that somebody told me about.
I wasn't very pleased with the report because I do not
think that they accurately represented the
differences between the department. I will give you an example.
When they looked at our immunization program,
they compared our putting shots in arms and the
county's putting shots in arm. That is
a minor part of our immunization program.
We have relationships with all of the providers within
Houston and Harris County. We're a state contractor
that have to monitor our Vaccines for Children program and
all of that. None of that stuff was included, and so I think they
fell short of that. But to the core of your question,
there are a lot of things that we are doing with the county. We mentioned
our One Safe, Houston. The credible messenger stuff.
We have been working with them. There are some things that we already have
in place that they just missed.
We were in the middle of COVID My staff did send me responses,
but they weren't that complimentary, so I didn't send them.
But we are in the process of working with the county, and what
we're going to do is come up with an MoU that really
will formalize the relationships that we have.
What I'm looking at is actually modeling it after an
interlocal agreement that I'm familiar with between the City of
Austin and Travis County. And I lived that life for
years, and so I know how that can be modeled. Thank you. I'd appreciate just
being kept in the loop on that. I'll do it. Thank you.
Council member Abby Cayman. Hi, Director.
Hi. First off, I really want
to recognize the department under your leadership for everything during
COVID We quickly talk about COVID and talk about shots and
arms, but the extent to which you and
the entire department have had to deal with not
only an unprecedented global pandemic, but the primary purpose,
you all were at the tip of the spear in terms of the response to
that. So thank you to everyone for
everything that you did and continue to do because it's
still ongoing. But on top of all of that, all the programs you continue to
run. Working with my office on the lead survey that we did in Friedman's
town, even just on the phone right now trying to work through some
of the formula shortage issues. You all continue to
be that first line of response and caring
for Houstonians every single day to that point. I don't know if you mentioned it.
How many Houstonians does the health department serve?
Well, there are different answers to that question
because it depends on the program. For the most part,
our department covers all of Houston, so the total
population of Houston. But for certain programs,
we cover all of Harris County. The Immunization program that
I mentioned earlier, one would think that our responsibility
is only the city of Houston, but it's not. It's all
of Harris County. We are the
state's point for Immunizations within all of Harris County
for our laboratory services. And I mentioned this. We actually have
a 17 county catchment area. So it really
depends on the program. But our core
is Houston, our Seed to succeed program, because we partially fund it
through grants. We service all of the school districts within the
region, not just HISD.
I appreciate that answer in the context I'm going to switch gears
really quickly. I'm going to ask an unpleasant question.
Looking at page nine. The Swimming Pool
Safety Fund.
I'm not as familiar with that program. And given
the fact that I don't want to be asking this question, I don't want us
to be in the position where we aren't going to have pools open this
summer. What we've heard from the Parks Department is because we don't have enough lifeguards,
we're going to have to reduce the number of pools open. Does that impact
the Pool Safety Fund in terms of operation or what's needed there?
We will. Patrick Key
is our assistant director, and shortly after he came in,
naomi Macias, who is newly appointed assistant
Director, was actually over consumer in that.
But several years ago, we developed
a strategy where we cross train people to make sure that
when swimming pool season arrived,
we were able to redeploy staff to actually ensure
that pools were inspected. It's one of the programs where
I get calls from my neighbor if my community pool
is not open or there's a problem with it. So it's like that. So the
resources that are allocated here are still being utilized even though the
public pools may be limited. In operations,
we inspect parks pools. Actually, that was one of the first things I did when
I came here. Joe and his folks were inspecting their own pools,
and we had an agreement that it would probably be
best if the Health Department, which inspected all other public
pools, inspected parks pools. Also.
I'll follow up on the question. I know my time is I'll put you
back in the car. Thank you, council Member Jackson. Thank you.
And thank you, Director Williams, for just all your work
and just the partnership. I know my office worked closely with you.
We were able to get in the incredible messenger program rolled
out and other initiatives. So just thank you and your staff for just
your commitment. As I'm looking at the major services and
I see all the services that your major
services under Human Services, the highlighted ones, is just disturbing
to see that. There's no dollars allocated for General
fund dollars allocated for these services, like Aging and Disabilities
and Reentry program. This is Human Services.
And so my question to you is, how many grant
writers do you have? Because it seemed like you're spending all your time writing grants
to serve the people. Usually in health departments,
the folks that direct the programs
write the grants. We don't have special grant writers,
except sometimes our planners
or analysts will write grants. But you will find
people all over our department writing grants.
Okay. I know recently with
the One Safe Houston, there was anywhere
from I know there was a lot of money from the ARPA dollars.
So does the budget include those dollars,
or is it we did not include opera dollars.
We did not include the opera dollars in this report because
we were still going through the process. Okay, all right.
It would only add $2 million to the budget.
Okay, well, we need those. I'm talking about from my department. Oh,
really? Yes. I know how to know that. Maybe three,
but I'm at you only 1 million for
reentry, and then I think a half million for
Credible Messenger, and then maybe another million for
street interventions.
Okay, thank you, sir. All right,
Council Member Cayman,
I'll submit a question to you all related to the pool fund,
so I can understand a little bit more. But lastly, Director, you've already
flagged some of the needs. And what I'm asking every department
is, as we look ahead, we have the financial constraints imposed by the city based
on revenue caps and other things. But looking ahead,
what do we need to be aware of on the horizon for the needs of
the Health Department? I think I
mentioned the areas that I think need most support.
Chronic disease is something that I think we need a further investment in
maternal and child health issues and certainly youth
balance issues. But the thing
that also that we
need to look at are some of those wraparound services
that we need to provide to clients in order to be successful regardless
of the core program that they're accessing.
For example, for years, even in our program
as Chorus TV,
our staff had to find sources for food,
sometimes housing, to ensure that the clients were
readily accessible so that they could take their TV medicine.
And that's for the overall protection of the community.
I don't want to just say, yes, we need more
General Fund money, and leave you with the impression that we're
not aggressively looking for
increased revenue. We've been very active statewide
looking at the transition from the 1115 waiver.
There is uncompensated care fund. We're trying to
maximize our ability to draw down funds on,
and of course, we continue to seek grants.
Director, I want to thank you again for your presentation. To you and your entire
team, we thank you all for all that you do. We have immense
appreciation for the work that continues,
especially during the pandemic. That was a
time of real uncertainty, in a time that we were continuously moving,
continuously trying to react, and from setting up the testing
sites to setting up the vaccine
sites, all the logistics that went on with that
through your leadership and your entire staff and team, we want to say thank you
for all that you do. Thank you. And you were dismissed.
We have four virtual speakers and
two in person speakers. We will start with the virtual
speakers. The first is melissa Martinez,
please press star six.
Melissa Martinez, please press star six.
Geo Grocer, please press star six to unmute.
Geogroph star
six to unmute.
Jason Oliver hello,
and thank you for the health presentation.
It's really concerning to kind of hear health come back year
after year, saying that they really could do quite a
bit in terms of, say, chronic disease, youth violence, and maternal
and child health with more general fund dollars.
I'm interested because you talked about that's, what you would prioritize in
terms of programming. Have you priced out any programs for
these areas that could be implemented during fiscal year 2023?
And then second,
because youth violence, of course, seems like an issue that we should really care about
right now. Second, behavioral health interventions announced and approved during
last year's budget don't appear to have been implemented yet, and it sounds like
those aren't housed there. But are those initiatives housed
within the Health Department? And then why is implementation seemingly
delayed? I'm going to start with your
first question. Many times the priorities of the department
is going to be led by the director of that department. So they are the
ones to identify certain programs that
they believe are beneficial, and they will put those in as line
items for us to consider and put forth.
Of course, there can always be additional programs and additional dollars that
would be needed for advancing those programs,
but that discretion remains with the director.
And your second question was my
second question was about the behavioral health interventions that were announced
last year, right. All of the MCOT teams that were
especially important as alternative responders are
those housed within the Health Department. And then what's going
on with the delay in implementation? Why is implementation
taking a while? We're going
to have to get back to you on that particular question to make sure that
we give you the specifics. So if you want to please send
us that question via email to District E at
houst gov. We'll get back to you shortly.
Okay, thank you. You're welcome.
Amanda Psy.
Hi. Thank you. I'm a resident of
District I, and I just wanted to
echo my kind of sadness
to hear that it sounds like support for programs
that the speaker really cared about. See, to succeed,
reentry my Brother's Keeper, things like that are
losing money. Can you share a little bit more about
the 1115 wafer and
then yeah. Is there anything that could be done
to help continue the support of these programs?
So the support of the programs not only come from, of course, the general fund,
but throughout the year, the directors do look to get
grant dollars that fund many of the programs that you were
speaking about. As council members, we also have council district service
funds where we work directly with the department to understand
their needs and identify ways in which we can support
specific programs that are unique to our community. So when it comes
to reentry or first responders, I know my office has allocated
dollars towards the My Brothers Keeper program, and so that's
ways in which we can assist and also supplement the department
with specific programming.
Next is okay,
did you have a thank you? Okay, you will?
Yes. I also just wanted to ask
about support for domestic violence
programs. Are there any initiatives
that would fall under Houston Health for that?
I believe there are, but let us make sure that we get you a specific
answer on that. I know that they work in collaboration with the Houston Police Department,
and many of us have an interest in ensuring that
we have dollars of programming towards domestic violence.
So please submit that answer directly to District E at Houst
Gov and we will respond promptly.
Next is Saba Blanding.
Hi, I wanted to follow up on that about domestic violence.
Yesterday, Council Member Martin asked the chief of Police what we should do
about domestic violence. Then a speaker shared that they were a survivor
of domestic violence. I did not hear anyone take the opportunity to ask them
what would have helped them. Domestic violence is a health issue, and my
question is, what efforts is the city making to engage survivors
in organizations such as Houston Area Women's Center to
address interrupting domestic violence, not just once it's
happened? And then, what is being done to specifically help support
the health and well being of Houstonians in possession of female reproductive organs?
According to the 2020 Report,
texas has 35 maternal deaths in 100,000.
To give some perspective, the national maternal mortality
rate for 2020 was 23.8 deaths per 100,000
live births, compared with a rate of 20.1 in 2019. And of
course, there are current and upcoming restrictions to accessing abortion health care.
Great questions as it pertains to domestic violence, I know
within the mayor's new One Safe Houston plan, I believe he directed
a million dollars towards the Houston Area Women's Center,
and those are additional dollars that came through
the Cares Act, no matter of fact, ARPA dollars.
And so that's one way in which we as a council are trying to assist
with providing more resources on domestic violence.
But I believe council Member Cayman, did you want to chime in?
PABA, thank you for the question. And this is just a few examples, and we'd
be happy to follow up. I think the city is trying to leverage
all community partners, not just City of Houston, including the Harris
County Domestic Violence Coordinating Council going back
to COVID, and I can speak from COVID on right, the no
COVID abuse program. So what we found is with
domestic abuse, a lot of survivors were trapped at
home with their families. Motion to extend.
Sure. So the city launched and
brought together community partners to launch that,
working with Hawk to do online reporting,
texting services, anything to get the word out and also educate
and help. But in addition to that, the mayor added in into
the Office of Human Trafficking, a specific charge now
also to include domestic violence in that. So that is now in
the mayor's office as a permanent office.
In addition to that, throughout COVID, the additional housing funding
that we provided. Right. So you have the issues with
housing during the pandemic, you can't keep everyone in a shelter and
there was an increased need. So city funding,
council funding, hotels, additional services,
job training that was actually launched, partnerships to
actually train people. Because one of the things that happens with domestic violence,
you end up in a cycle because you are dependent on that abuser
financially. So the city is actually starting to focus on job training
programs. And we can get you more information on that.
There's a whole list of things, but that's just a few examples,
not just the immediate response, immediate funding to Dart HPD,
but the holistic approach
that the city is trying to take in addressing the issue.
Are you also studying this within your Women's commission?
Is this one of the action items
that you all are looking at? I can't speak for the
Women's Commission because, again, that's an independent commission under the charge
of the mayor. But I do believe they are looking at that issue as well.
It's remaining at the forefront in a multitude
of ways. And then the city is supporting Houston Area
Women's Center in their expansion of their new campus.
That's going to be in District D,
but there's a lot of extraordinary work
happening in that space. Great, thank you.
Thank you for your questions,
Mr. Broderick butler.
My name is Broderick Butler. I'm from northeast Houston. I respect
the health director's detailed responses to numerous members
of council. It would have been nice if he could have done the same
for the four public speakers. But if I
were here to ask him, I'd like to know from that list
that he gave us with all the red lettering, what his priorities
would be. So if you want to put yourself in his shoes and tell me
what his priorities would be for funding for the unfunded
projects that he has, I would love to hear that. Lastly, I'd like to make
a statement. I would like to acknowledge my council member,
Tossa Jackson, today. She stood 10ft tall
for me because she embodied the saying that the only
thing necessary for the triumph of evil is for good
men and women to do nothing. Thank you.
Thank you. No answer.
I didn't hear a question in any of that. I said to give me the
priorities from the list of the unfunded things the health director show.
No, you said to put ourselves in the shoes of the director.
You guys are answering the questions. If you would like
to ask us directly. We asked detailed questions of each of you,
gave detailed answers to each of you to the questions
you gave. We didn't have that opportunity. So since he
is not here,
we can't talk over each other. So if you could give me these answers
for the list of the top priorities he would have
to choose from off that list of unfunded things,
I would appreciate it. If you can't, you can't. If you can, you can.
Directors report to the mayor. We as council members, report to
the public. So if you have a question for us, then you
can give that to us. Now. We can take your question and submit
that over to the director to provide an answer to you from his
standpoint, but we're not going to step in his shoes. And the
reason in which you all are speaking to us as a council is
because we report to you. The directors report to
the mayor in his administration, and so they were asked to leave,
and that's why their questions are being reported to us from the public. Okay?
So if you have a direct question to us, we can answer. If not,
if the question is for the director, we will submit for you,
and then we will provide their response. I'm not here to talk to you.
I'm here to talk to the director. So therefore, there's a
flaw in that logic of who I provide
the question to. He answered detailed questions
from you, and he couldn't do the same for us because
he was dismissed. So therefore, that is a
flaw in this whole process. And I didn't want to
go here, but since we are, that's a flaw in this
process. Each of these individuals that have stood before us are
compensated very well. And the question previously that I wanted to
say that the airport director said he gave
a sterling list of people that he lost.
But you know what I would have said to him? Competency gets compensation.
And you're supposed to build up people that leave you
and go to different departments in different countries and different sections
and exemplary and show that I was produced by the
Houston airport system. So that's what I would have said
to him. It's sad, but next man
up. Thank you, sir.
We have no more public speakers. And that concludes our health
department presentation.